is there a point where like uh
a rock bottom of like [ __ ] dude i'm
shooting up in my toes now or am i
shooting shut up bleach one time
that was pretty bad rejected bleach yeah
because so i'm living with this this
woman named annette and these projects
that i no way people really belong in
it's uh and i couldn't leave the house
to go cop right it was like a really
rough neighborhood and uh so she would
go but one day i didn't have any money
so she goes out the cop and when she
leaves i get her her needles and her
spoons and i'm like
putting water on the spoons and getting
like her leftovers like a hot shot of
her leftovers but i'm also using her
needle scraping the resin yeah so you're
like i'm shooting up her blood so i
should probably make some bleach into it
but there's a little bit of hair running
but i'm in a hurry right i'm in a hurry
because the net's gone so time is of the
essence because if she comes back and
catches me in her [ __ ] she's gonna [ __ ]
me up so i'm like i have a thing of
water and a thing of bleach you don't
[ __ ] with it nothing of blood and the
hair
so i'm rushing to i get the
water clean out and then the bleach i'm
i'm hurrying up and pushing it through
and then i intend to put the needle in
the water to then put on the res but i'm
in such a hurry i put the bleach on the
res and i cook it and when it comes back
it has a yellow tint just like heroin
does anyways bleach yeah so i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i have a great shot here like
i'm gonna actually get high off this
and i put it in me and it's and i
probably maybe like five cc's so it's
not much it's like
and about
two in
i feel like an
internal inferno that is like but i'm in
such denial that it's not heroin i still
continue to put it in because like i
can't believe that wow dude and at the
time i have warrants for my arrest
so although i realize i just shot up
this bleach i cannot call 9-1-1 because
i'll go to jail so i just sit in the
corner and just dump water over my head
over and over because you're on fire
yeah suck
man so you're telling me that like if
that you
you can shoot up bleach and you're okay
yeah i didn't i'm here five cc's five
cc's wow
so it's about that much but it was it
was probably wow dude does any part of
you want to be like dude i'm going to
film a gnarly stunt hey everybody this
is i'm brandon novak and this is
shooting up bleach absolutely nothing
does anybody watch
you're not going to do it
for the record could i have that bit
because there was the joke that's like
you can get rid of covid by like taking
blues
well it didn't cure me of the [ __ ]
hepatitis i had so i would like do the
bleach yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude